Russian President Vladimir Putin blames
the Ukrainian president for the standoff
claiming it's a move to boost his
ratings it's clearly a product a
provocation organised I think it was the
president himself
ahead of the presidential election
international pressure against Russia is
building with talk of further sanctions
US president Donald Trump has threatened
to cancel a meeting scheduled with
President Putin at this week's g20
summit meanwhile Ukrainians are
preparing for a new phase of war with
the conflict showing no signs of
stopping let's go through this with kurt
volker who's a US Special Representative
for Ukraine negotiations he's also a
former US ambassador to NATO
welcome to DW and just explain to us
what the America's position in this
latest outbreak of hostilities is well
first off that this is an act of
aggression by Russia that these were
Ukrainian vessels traveling peacefully
seeking to go through this Kerch straits
to Ukrainian port they were not allowed
to go through they turned around and as
they turned around and they were
attacked and then boarded by Russians
and as we just saw on the report Russia
confiscated the ships and arrested the
sailors so both an illegal act to begin
with and then followed on by another
illegal act of attacking this this
vessel so when Russia says this was a
Ukrainian act of provocation the US
response is well I'm not sure how this
can be a provocation a sovereign state
has a navy it's moving vessels from one
of its ports to another one of its ports
through its own waters the problem here
is that Russia has claimed to as taken
Crimea has claimed to annex it claims
that the waters around Crimea are now
Russian waters and claims that despite a
2003 agreement with Ukraine that Russia
has unilateral control over access to
the sea vessel
and then fired upon these vessels I
don't see anything that Ukraine did here
that could be conceived of as
provocative
it is however challenging Russia's
assertions to having taken these
Ukrainian pieces of territory in water
and so that the Russian game here is
what the this area of Ukraine is of
Crimea it's ours well the first off that
is the first thing they say it is theirs
they're never giving it back they've
annexed if they say it's done but
secondly it's no matter what they do and
in this case they've actually fired on
Ukrainian naval vessels no firing back
by the Ukrainians by the way they've
then adopted the people they've
confiscated the ships and then they
blame the Ukrainians for doing that so
what's the United States gonna do about
it
well I think the first thing is we were
coordinating very closely with our
European allies and partners we have a
robust policy of sanctions in place we
work with Ukrainians on strengthening
their defense capabilities trying to
strengthen resiliency in Ukraine and our
European allies are doing the same
there's talk as we just saw on this
report about possible additional
sanctions from Europe we think that's
worth considering alternatively there
are sanctions on the books that perhaps
are not being implemented as rigorously
as they could be and that's something
else that some of our European allies
could okay you see the world looks on
and says well sanctions have already
been applied and Russia just keeps
marching around that area around Crimea
and say yeah despite the sanctions this
is ours this is ours and we'll have that
as well and I think I think that that
misses a couple of things first off I
think this could have been a lot worse
and I think the pressure that the West
has put back against Russia for having
invaded eastern Ukraine in particular
and applying sanctions there has created
some deterrent effect and Russia not
wanting to escalate in a full-scale
conflict not seeking to take new
territory I think that the defensive
support for Ukraine contributes to that
as well I also think that there's a lot
of discussion in Moscow now is this
really working out for Russia when you
saw what happened a few weeks ago with
Ukrainian Orthodox Church for example
they're demanding independence from the
russian orthodox church precisely
because the Ukrainian people are
alienated because of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine and killing Ukrainians so
that they've lost the goodwill of
Ukrainian people
have been there for centuries so it's a
it's a major loss for Russia really do
you see any role for a military response
in this I don't see any any desire by
anybody to fight against Russia to
retake this territory the Ukrainians
cannot and should not do that there's no
desire in the West to do that but what
we need to do is to deter further
Russian advances as being too costly and
too useless for them in order to create
the conditions for a negotiation to
re-establish peace and restore the
territory but do you think do you
realistically expect the the territory
to be reestablished you talk about
deterring Russia from further expansion
and my reading of the situation is that
once Russia has that bit of Ukraine
it'll it'll be happy that this is what
it wanted it's got it now no I don't
think that's right I think particularly
if you look at the DOM bus the part of
eastern Ukraine where there is still
active fighting every night this is not
territory that is terribly important to
Russia as the territory in itself it is
because it provides a foothold into the
rest of Ukraine provides a means of
influence the problem is that that
influence is backfired it has produced
exactly the opposite of what Russia
wanted so there is an incentive for
Russia to say let you know let's
negotiate a peace agreement here and
what the Minsk agreements actually say
is that the territory would be restored
to Ukrainian control and Russia is a
party to those agreements so it's a
matter of finding the mechanisms can we
get this implemented so that we can at
least establish peace in that part
Crimea it's gonna be a longer-term
problem but in eastern Ukraine I think
there is some hope good token do you
thank you for joining us i kurt volker
are you a special representative for
ukraine thank you